So far we've strongly encouraged using
native elements because they give you
focus, keyboard support, and
built in semantics essentially for free.
But there are instances when
native HTML won't cut it.
The Web Accessibility Initiatives
Accessible Rich Internet Applications
spec is good for bridging areas
where there are accessibility
issues that can't be
managed with native HTML.
I don't have time to keep saying the Web
Accessibility Initiatives Accessible
Rich Internet Applications
specification.
So for the rest of the course, we'll
be calling it by its much friendlier
nickname, ARIA, but you'll often see
it referred to as Wai-Aria as well,
which is helpful if you
want to search for it.
Aria works by allowing you to
specify attributes on elements
which modify the way that element is
translated into the accessibility tree.
Let's take a look at a really basic
example to show how this works.
If we create a plain check
box we saw in less than three
that a screen readable
announcer as a check box,
tell you its label if it has one and
tell you whether it is checked or not.
And similarly uses of other assistive
technologies like voice control
will be able to operate it.
However, what happens if for
some reason we decide,we really need
to reimplement a basic checkbox?
Well, for a start, we know from lesson
two that we need to make it focusable
and handle the same keyboard
interactions as a native check box.
But what happens if we then try
to use it with a screen reader?
The screen reader gives us no
indication that the element is meant to
be a check box.
Sighted users can see the visual cues
which indicate the check box pattern,
but nothing is announced
to screen reader users.
Using ARIA allows us to tell the screen
reader that extra information.
To give you an idea how it works, let's
look at this toy fake check box example.
Just to clarify,
there's very little reason you'd
ever want to write code like this.
You're usually much better off
styling a regular check box, but
this gives us a taste of
what ARIA allows us to do.
So I'll run Chrome Vox
light on this page,
to show what things are like
before we do anything.
>> Tim-tams, mint slices.
>> We have a checked and
unchecked custom check box up here.
Chrome Vox reads out the labels
as tim-tams and mint slices,
but doesn't give us any indication
that either one is a check box.
If we compare that with
the native checkbox.
>> [SOUND] Tim-Tams check box checked.
[SOUND] Mint slices,
check box not checked.
>> ChromeVox reads out the label,
the role, and the checked state of each,
and plays a small earcon, which is that
small sound effect you might have heard
at the start, to give a quick indication
of the role and checked state as well.
So I'm going to pop open DevTools,
and add an ARIA role of check box and
an ARIA-checked state to each
of those custom check boxes.
So the first one gets
an aria-checked state of true and
the second one will get
an aria-checked state of false.
Note that I need to explicitly specify
that aria-checked is true or false.
Just adding the attribute
with an empty string,
like we often do with other HTML
attributes, won't do the job.
ARIA attributes always need
to have explicit values.
So now we're going to
close the dev tools and
start up Chomebook slide again.
>> [SOUND] TIm-Tams checkbox checked,
[SOUND] mint slices check
box not checked,
[SOUND] Tim-Tams check box checked.
>> So now we can hear that there's
really no difference from ChromeVox's
point of view, between the fake check
boxes and the native check boxes.
They all sound identical, so
adding that role attribute and
that aria-checked attribute
causes the node in the accessibility
tree to have the desired role and state,
without changing anything else about
that node's appearance or behavior.
In terms of the accessibility tree,
what ARIA does is allow you to
essentially do some tree surgery.
We take the accessibility tree as
generated from the plain HTML tree,
add ARIA and
get a different accessibility tree.
It may be subtly different or
radically different depending on
what attributes we use and where.
However, we need to keep in mind that
this is the only thing ARIA changes.
It doesn't change anything about the
behavior of the element it's added to.
For example, it's not going to
make the element focusable or
add keyboard event listeners.
We still need to do the work by making
sure we're keeping the promise we're
making by telling assistive
technology that it has that role.
We'll be looking closer at what that
means throughout this lesson, but
I'll point out right now that
it's no coincidence that we're
covering ARIA after the lesson
on focus and keyboard.